Men ask you “what do you bring to the table?”
and women are like,
“I am the table”
I hear you, I see you,
but let's dissect that a little.
I'm gonna be honest,
some of our tables are coming with three legs.
you wanna be the table?
then we should be making sure that our table is strong and firm,
comes with four legs,
and can stand on its own!
we truly need to be honest with ourselves,
are we actually coming with strong foundations?
or are we three legged tables?
as women we often struggle to regulate our own emotions
so you're probably asking okay
how do I create a firm foundation?
learn how to emotionally regulate,
set boundaries,
and heal past traumas,
don't be self centered.
understanding what you have to offer doesn't mean the world revolves around you
it's not, that's not what life is about okay
life is about serving others,
friends, family members,
a man that you plan to marry.
if you can't emotionally regulate,
be there for others,
and understand that the world does not revolve around you.
we have some work to do,
and you have to work on your table
be Bob the builder
and work on your table!
okay your table should come with four legs and stand on its own.
next time a man ask you
what do you bring to the table?
you can be honest and say,
I am the table!
a strong stable table!
I'm healed from past trauma,
I'm emotionally regulated,
and I love to serve others.